good evening from London welcome to Pi
Morgan on sensor two and a half years
ago the dukee and Duchess of Sussex sat
down with Oprah Winfrey to air a slew of
Grievances and claims about the royal
family that they had deserted the most
incendiary claim was that members of the
royal family had raised quotes concerns
in multiple conversations about what
skin color baby Archie's skin would
be and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like hold up hold up there sever
there's several conversations there's a
conversation with you with Harry
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look
like and and you're not going to tell me
who had the
conversation I think that would be very
damaging to them okay compartmentalized
ConEd that if he were
to
Brown that that would be a problem are
you saying that I wasn't able to follow
up with why but that if that's the
Assumption you're making I think that
feels like a pretty safe one you see
that's just an allegation of racism
right there it's not ambiguous that is
Megan marle accusing a member of the
roal family of being racist judging
somebody according to the color of their
skin and how Brown they are there's no
room for thinking it's anything
else now the impact of that claim was
extraordinary the claims were reported
breathlessly across the world tens of
millions of people hundreds of millions
were left with the unavoidable
impression that Britain is a racist
country with races at the heart of our
royal family but just the fact that
there is is according to both of them
this
ongoing blatant racism not only in the
UK tabloid press but in the family but
for some people in this country a
blanket denial of racism like the one
that we heard from Prince William
yesterday just isn't enough Buckingham
pal is racis among the more shocking
revelations was that of sort of overt
racism she faced within the royal family
but here it is a couple that's truly in
love and the thing that you want to
question is their skin tone I hope all
those people are having severe second
thoughts or buers remorse about
believing what Mega marle and Prince
Harry said I don't need to because that
day I said I didn't believe a word of it
and I had to leave my job because I
didn't believe them even though I think
they were lying well for two and a half
years there's been frenzy speculation
about how who these supposedly racist
Royals are just about every single
member of the royal households been
implicated in the rumors at some point
and that surely isn't fair is it just
guilt by Collective
Association especially if you believe as
I do as I've always said that the claims
in my opinion are completely and utterly
baseless that speculation reached fever
pitch again this week because of his
weasly lick spittle omed scobby he's the
client journalist of the sussexes he's
always the first to publish their Soviet
Style official statements and defend
their
indefensible Deeds he's like that guy
comical alley do you remember him who
fronted up for Saddam Hussein in the
Iraq War would literally say we've got
him on the run as the American howt says
we're coming over his head well Megan
marle famously denied briefing scobby
for his last book Finding freedom but
then she was forced a few months after
it came out to apologize in court and
admit that actually she had she' briefed
one of her aids to go and tell scob be
all the L all the laundry so when it
emerged that the leg's book contained
new details on those race accusations
well let's just say I made my own
assumptions about where scobby could
have got that information from because
it wasn't King
Charles so that only leaves the other
person on the end of that correspondence
that's Megan Markle or maybe Harry a
husband or maybe one of their mutual
friends the scobby keeps boasting he has
Kobe says he knew the names of the
accused Royals but couldn't use them for
legal reasons that's in the English
version of his book then as everybody
now knows the names suddenly appeared in
a Dutch translation of the book and by
appear I mean they were sent to
journalists who couldn't believe what
they were reading they went into
bookstores where people could buy it
well last night I decided this was all
ridiculous and it was time to name the
two roles implicated in those racist ISM
claims they are as I said last night
King Charles Prince Charles as he was
then and Catherine the Princess of Wales
I did that for several reasons first the
speculation was once again raging out of
control as it has for two and a half
years second it made no sense that Dutch
journalists and Dutch people who bought
copies before the publisher withdrew
them would know these names members of
our royal family when the British people
were prevented from knowing them thirdly
once you know the names it becomes
blindingly obvious to anyone with even
half a brain
that these allegations are ridiculous
whatever your view of the monarchy I
don't think any serious person really
believes that anything they've seen or
heard from King Charles or the Princess
of Wales suggests they have even the
tiniest racist bone in their bodies or
would judge anybody according to the
shade of their skin and once again it's
worth remembering what Prince Harry
eventually said about these accusations
when he was promoting his book and
before we play the clip just to remind
you after launching This Racist
bombshell two and a half years ago it
never got mentioned again not in the
six-part Netflix series which mentioned
everything else in their lives not in
the 12-part podcast for Spotify that
Mega marle did never mentioned and it
never got mentioned in Harry's over 400
page book 150,000 words of stuff about
his entire life but not a mention of the
opposed racism by members of his own
family which he had launched as a
missile against that family on Oprah
Winfrey so this is what he said to Tom
bradby at ITN at the start of this year
when promoting the book where he didn't
mention
it in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well of the British press
said that right I did did Megan ever
mention that they they
racist she said they were troubling
comments about concern about his skin
color right wouldn't you describe that
as essentially racist I wouldn't not
having lived within that family God he's
such a dim wi isn't he he's just dim as
ditchwater he literally thinks we're
going to watch the clips back from oah
and not think that she was saying that
the RO family had been racist how dumb
does he think we
are so Harry performs this dramatic
U-turn oh it was never we never meant to
suggest they were racist it was the
terrible British press they were the
ones who said it was racism we just
meant unconscious bias you know what
that's become a euphemism for we
actually haven't got any evidence of
someone being racist we just think it's
kind of unconscious on the sly right
it's kind of there but we can't prove it
it's like we think they might be yeah
not good enough not when it comes to
members of the royal family his
reputations are on a global
stage so why should I stand back and let
a proven liar like omed scobby a man who
claims in this book as a fact that I
have regular phone chats with Queen
Camila regular do you know how many
times I've spoken to queen killer on the
phone in my entire 58e life
zero not
once it's not just not regular it's
never
happened we've never had a phone
chat so he's a liar and he lied again
about when apparently I called Mega
marel princess Pinocchio on that fateful
last day good Morning Britain apparently
Kim immediately contacted me to thank me
on behalf of the firm no she didn't
another lie complete
lie so SC be prepared to lie about me
about these little things which don't
really am amount to a row of beans why
should we believe anything else he has
to say all he's doing is dragging the
whole royal family through the mud all
over again reigniting these racism
charges because he wants to sell books
and make money well scobby gave another
interview this morning Tu this morning
in which he again deny working with mega
Markle and he also denied ever using the
names in any draft of his
book I'm as frustrated as everyone else
I make it very clear in this book that I
in every way possible want to adhere to
the laws surrounding this subject it's
why I've been very careful in how it's
described in the book and it's why I've
never spoken about it
beyond what I've said in the public
domain before the reality is though is
that this is information that is not
privy just to
me a liar a barefaced liar he wants us
to believe that he only submitted a
draft in the English version which never
mentioned the names but that somebody in
the Netherlands got hold of it and added
the names and added entire paragraph in
one part of this into the manuscript
before it went to the printers a lethal
sabur
who would do that have you ever ever met
any author in history because I haven't
who's had that happen to their
manuscript on the way to the printers in
a foreign country like the Netherlands
they've got into the manuscript and
changed it without the author knowing
anything about it no it doesn't pass
what we call the smell test it's the
scobby stinks when it comes to the smell
test now he thinks I'm completely wrong
assum an earlier version of his book
included the names and was sent for
translation only for his lawyers to take
them out of the final Edition which I
think is the most likely explanation
it's therefore rather inconvenient for
him the Dutch translator has told
reporters tonight that she'd only
translated what was written down on the
manuscript she said the names of the
Royals were there in black and white I
didn't add them I just did what I was
paid to do and that was translate the
book from English into
Dutch now at this point the deafening
Silence from Harry and Megan becomes a
little more than deafening it becomes
pretty shameful because they usually
race to condemn and denounce any press
reports that we dislike particularly if
it involves any leaks from private
correspondents Mega marle ironically was
forced to admit that she colluded with
om scobby on his last book in a court
action she took against a newspaper over
private correspondence with her father
so why have they remained So Silent
about om sco's lies and also about his
leaking of the private correspondence
between Mega Markle and King Charles
that contain these names is it because
they were involved in him getting this
information is it because I don't know
the tooth Theory came down and did it or
Santa Claus or for want of a better a
better third example
Pinocchio the public can of course make
their own minds up about all of this it
shouldn't take long and the same goes
for the baseless accusations of Royal
racism nobody I repeat really thinks
King Charles or the Princess of Wales
are racist nobody that's part of the
reason actually why I decided to put
their names out there it's called
Lancing the boil it's called removing
what has been a simmering threat
deployed by Megan and Harry and deployed
by Omen scobby as an unspoken threat
we've got these names and if we if we
don't get what we want we're going to
use them well now they can't do that
I've been at the sharp end of British
journ for 30 years I've seen World Cris
he come and go I remember after Diana
died everybody predicted that was the
end of the monarchy but it wasn't the
monarchy survived and it thrived with
our great Queen Elizabeth II and it's
doing so again now with King Charles
who's doing a brilliant job as the head
of our great royal family and the head
of the great monarchy the only crisis I
think that we're facing at the moment
moment this end game as omed scobby puts
it is an end game for omed
scobby and potentially depending on how
they respond to this to the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex because this morning
the Times newspaper the paper of record
in this country the paper read by
opinion formers politicians those who
matter said that it was time that King
Charles removed the Royal titles from a
couple who seemed to want to destroy the
royal family in the monarchy but
simultaneously make millions and
millions of dollars by trading off their
Royal titles from an institution they
keep trashing that may well be the
beginning of the end game for their
Royal
duplicity